I was in a relationship for a couple of
years but I stopped when things got too
hectic and it had nothing to do with
them it was just strictly I couldn't you
couldn't manage it exactly Jenna Ortega
opens up about her dating life during a
recent appearance on the armchair expert
podcast with Dax Shepard and Monica
padman there's so much going on Jenna
who was most recently romantically
linked to Asher angel in 2018
says she doesn't think she's emotionally
ready to date I almost don't even find
myself interested but I think a big part
of it is self-esteem like I don't think
I'm ready to be that vulnerable or
trusting with someone the Wednesday star
who's booked and busy with projects like
Scream 6 coming up I'm very very excited
ads it wouldn't be fair to enter a
relationship when she doesn't have the
time for one if there's one thing I'm
gonna focus on which is probably
something I need to change it's going to
be my work I definitely feel like
there's been a shift in my life and I
feel a shifts in energy and change and I
feel like it's definitely a new time in
my life so it's been a bit of an
adjustment on the podcast Jenna also
opens up about the extra work she has to
put in for season one of the Netflix
series Wednesday including advocating
for her character during the writing
process her being in a love triangle
yeah made no sense there was a line
about like a stress that she has to wear
for a school dance and she said oh my
God I love it I can't believe I said
that I literally hate myself and I had
to go no there's no way there was times
on that set where I even became almost
unprofessional since where I just
started changing lines the script
supervisor thought that like I was going
with something and then I would have
been done with the writers and they
would be like wait what happened to the
scene and I would have to go through and
explain why I couldn't do certain things
I grew very very protective of her yeah
whether it's Wednesday or her dating
life Jenna Ortega is going to stay true
to herself
[Music]
thank you